20 عاما على اطلاق قناه العربيه 20 عاما
اصبحت خلالها رائده بكل مشاريعها على
وسائل الاعلام والمنصات المختلفه المدير
العام للقناه العربيه والحدث ممدوح
المهيني تحدث عن سر نجاح الشبكه في لقاء
مع الزميله راويه العالمي في بودكاست
العربيه متابعه
بعتقد انه هذا جزء من ثقافه العمل ثقافه
العمل وشغف الناس بالمكان هذا السر النجاح
في محطات كثيره عندها ممكن تمويل اكبر
عندها عدد ناس اكبر عندها
قدرات اكبر من العربيه ولكن ما عندهم
القدر الكبير من النجاح لهذا ما استمروا
العربيه خلال عشرين سنه في نجاح مستمر
وهذا جزء من الشغف لما رجعت مع الزملاء
شفنا عدد المقابلات الكبير عدد التغطيات
عدد في زملائنا يعني يعني ما بسبب ذهب
وضحايا بسبب
هالشغف
للمهنه نفسها وللمحطه بشكل بشكل اساسي انا
اعتقد هذا السر الاساسي
يعني اذا حبينا العربي استمرت متالقه طيله
هذه السنوات
المدير العام لقناه العربيه ممدوح المهني
تحدث ايضا عن ابرز انجازات المرحله وعن
الانتقال الى الرياض وفي البودكاست قال
المهيني ان العربيه تحافظ على وجودها
وتنافس بقوه في كل مجالات وسائل الاعلام
المختلفه يمكن متابعه البودكاست كاملا على
بودكاست العربيه
حنا عندنا هدفين اساسيين اللي هو تقويه
الشاشه بشكل اساسي وهذا النعمله يوميا مع
الزملاء الاخبار يوميا اجتماعات كيف قدم
الماده ايش المقابل نعملها كيف نعمل
التغطيه عندنا الاجتماعات مستمره
نفس الشيء احنا ما ننسى يعني وجود الحضور
على منصات تواصل بس بطريقتنا الخاص يعني
استخدمنا واستثمرنا منصات التواصل طريقه
تناسب العربيه او تناسب الحدث او تناسب
موقع مواقع العربيه المختلفه فهذا جزء
اساسي من اللعبه لما يصير حدث كبير حدث
مهم حدث ضخم اغلب الناس يجي يشوف لانه
يعني هو يثق بقيمه المحطه يروح على تويتر
ويروح على فيسبوك ويروح على الانستجرام
يروح بالنسبه لي انا كلها هي بنها العربيه
كلها يعني تصف في مكان واحد
ف جزء من اساسي من استثمار السنوات
الماضيه كان انه يكون حاضرين في كل مكان